[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines avec au
programme de l'actualité des
infopratiques et aussi des idées de
sortie bonsoir Mathilde pour la
prochaine demi-heure
avec vous bien sûr les infos du jour et
on déroule tout de suite le programme de
ce 18 octobre
journée de grève interprofessionnelle à
l'appel de plusieurs syndicats pour le
pouvoir d'achat ça a été très compliqué
aujourd'hui dans de nombreux secteurs
ont fait le point dans les informations
du jour également cette mobilisation à
Versailles à l'occasion de la Journée
mondiale contre la douleur la quatrième
édition du festival imagos se poursuit
jusqu'au 20 décembre à un événement qui
mêle à rianticap dans ce cadre la pièce
la cabane de l'architecte de la
compagnie influencenne soit proposée
vendredi à plaisir c'est au théâtre
Coluche enlevé de rideau une création
avec des bénéficiaires de l'association
Art convergence et puis nous partirons à
rezeux en fin d'édition la naturaliste
Solène Boivin vous fait découvrir la
Haute Vallée de Chevreuse au cours de
balades commentées elles se tiennent
tout au long de l'année avec un
spectacle naturel qui évolue au gré des
quatre saisons
et deux invités également avec nous dans
la prochaine demi-heure Florence Camoin
bonsoir directrice du Théâtre Coluche le
TEC ou se tiendra la pièce dont on parle
dans un instant avec vous également
Jean-Luc Paillet bonsoir vous êtes
metteur en scène président de la
compagnie influencenne et je le disais
dans les titres vendredi vous proposerez
cette création c'est la cabane de
l'architecte ou la maintenus de Le
Corbusier de Louise Doutreligne vous
signez la mise en scène et je le disais
c'est donc au théâtre espace Coluche
théâtre Coluche de plaisir anciennement
théâtre espace Coluche j'allais la faire
au moins une fois dans cette émission le
théâtre a changé de nom il y a de cela
un an juste pour présenter déjà la
compagnon influencé en quelques mots bon
quelques mots c'est une compagnie
importante qui est basée en région
parisienne à l'est de Paris nous venons
un peu en voyage à l'ouest si j'ose dire
de la Seine-et-Marne jusque dans les
Yvelines du Val-de-Marne
mais là on est en résidence de création
c'est la deuxième fois que nous faisons
une grosse la création au teck
grâce à Florence camoille à son accueil
nous avions fait l'an dernier Vienne
1913 et prémices du pire qui un
spectacle qui a tourné au Festival
d'Avignon nous venons souvent au
festival Avignon et là notre compagnie
est en résidence donc depuis le mois de
mai pour la création cette nouvelle
création donc un spectacle autour de
l'architecture et d'un monsieur qui est
devenu architecte grâce à Le Corbusier
grâce à la main tendue Le Corbusier on
en dira plus tout à l'heure et c'est
dans le cadre du festival imago
puisqu'en lit en levée de rideau de
cette pièce il y aura une création votre
compagnie a travaillé avec l'association
Art convergence et il y a des
bénéficiaires qui jouent dans cette
création l'association Art convergence
qui accompagne des personnes atteintes
de maladies psychiques et donc le
festival imago aussi qu'est-ce que c'est
le festivalimago c'est la quatrième
édition c'est jusqu'au 20 décembre c'est
un énorme festival qui recouvre toute
l'Île-de-France et un peu au-delà qui
réunit de nombreux mais aussi des
médiathèques il y a le musée du quai
Branly qui est partenaire de cette
opération il y a eu la conférence de
presse de présentation donc c'est assez
fascinant et c'est vrai que autour de
l'architecture en fait je crois qu'il y
a une vraie mobilisation du public ça
c'est assez intéressant surtout dans nos
banlieues dans nos vies de nouvelles et
du coup j'avais pensé à l'association et
à reconvergence avec qui j'avais proposé
de de monter un projet autour de
l'architecture avec les résidents de
l'hôpital de plaisir mais alentours
aussi parce que ça regroupe
Saint-Germain-en-Laye ça regroupe
vraiment plusieurs structures et donc
l'idée c'était de faire plusieurs
ateliers les maquettes donc on accueille
une exposition de maquettes dans le hall
du théâtre mais aussi un mini spectacle
une création avec un texte original
autour de l'architecture qui est presque
une sorte de préalable d'éclaircissement
à ce qui va se produire sur scène
pendant le spectacle on en parlera tout
à l'heure dans le 7 8 Mathilde Franco a
suivre également avec vous on reste à
plaisir et on va parler de la Maison des
Femmes Calypso qui va bientôt s'agrandir
oui donc c'est une maison qui a ouvert
en janvier dernier et c'est une maison
qui a pour but de lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes mais pas que
il y a aussi un centre de planification
familiale donc on en parlera tout à
l'heure voilà pour le programme ce sera
dans un instant mais tout de suite la
météo
[Musique]
demain mercredi 19 octobre jour de la
saint René il devrait y avoir des
conditions similaires aujourd'hui dans
les Yvelines nuageux pour la matinée sur
le territoire avec du brouillard du côté
de Houdan Versailles à Mantes-la-Jolie
et où il fera avec 15 degrés ce sera à
14 degrés à Rambouillet le soleil où
est-il c'est la question qu'on pourra se
poser également demain mais vous en
apercevrez peut-être quelques rayons
rassurez-vous dans l'après-midi c'est
toujours très doux pour une mi-octobre
20 degrés à Versailles Rambouillet et
Mantes-la-Jolie 21 degrés à Houdan de la
pluie est annoncée pour la journée de
jeudi
[Musique]
les informations du jour avec un mot qui
était le maître mot on peut le dire
aujourd'hui patience avec cette journée
de grève interprofessionnelle Mathilde
qui vous a sans doute impacté dans les
Yvelines est-ce que c'est un mouvement
qui a été suivi et oui près de 150
points de rassemblement dans toute la
France transports publics routier
agroalimentaire commerce fonction
publique ils étaient tous dans la rue
pour réclamer une hausse des salaires et
pour s'opposer aux réquisitions des
grévistes selon l'éducation nationale
moins de 6% des enseignants se sont
mobilisés dans les Yvelines selon la CGT
cheminot un conducteur sur deux était en
grève d'ailleurs dans les zones de
Versailles trap et Rambouillet la grève
est reconduite à deux mains donc de
nouvelles perturbations seront donc à
prévoir dans les transports dans ces
secteurs aujourd'hui c'était également
Mathilde la Journée mondiale contre la
douleur effectivement Grégory essaie
dans ce cadre que le collectif soulagé
mais pas tué c'est mobiliser aujourd'hui
à Versailles revendique le déploiement
des soins palliatifs partout en France
on écoute leur porte-parole au micro de
Julien Leroy
département en France qui n'ont pas de
d'unités de soins palliatifs et puis des
départements enfin voilà tout le monde
n'a pas accès malheureusement à ses
soins alors que c'est un droit assez
dans la loi la loi santé de depuis 1999
on veut supprimer la souffrance pas
supprimer ceux qui souffre
une vie le collectif se prononce contre
le thanazi et le suicide assisté autre
rendez-vous c'est en ce moment la
semaine de l'intégration avec des
événements qui sont organisés par la
préfecture des Yvelines et à
Mantes-la-Jolie et bien c'est la
première ville des Yvelines qui
s'engagent pour l'accueil et
l'intégration tout à fait hier le préfet
délégué pour l'égalité des chances et la
directrice territoriale de l'Office
français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration était accueillis par le
maire de Mantes-la-Jolie ils ont signé
le tout premier projet territorial
d'accueil et d'intégration l'objectif
faciliter l'accès à la formation et à
l'emploi par l'apprentissage du français
on en a beaucoup parlé dernièrement avec
de multiples cyberattaques notamment un
hôpital en Essonne et demain justement
un événement sur la cyber sécurité et
proposer sur le territoire de 50 ans en
Yvelines effectivement Grégory top
départ d'horizon cyber demain à 9h30 ce
sera sur le campus de l'ESTACA le but
rassembler l'ensemble des acteurs
start-up innovante PME ou grands groupes
pour présenter et mettre en situation
des solutions de sécurité informatique
ce sera également l'occasion d'évoquer
les actualités autour de la cyber
sécurité ou encore les nouvelles
réglementations enfin c'est tout nouveau
50 ans en Yvelines va déployer de
nouvelles bandes de recharge pour les
voitures électriques oui
il s'agit de 50 nouveaux points de
recharge public qui seront proposés aux
utilisateurs les bornes déjà présentes à
morpa Coignières et Villepreux vont être
adaptés et modernisés vous aurez la
possibilité de brancher tous les types
de prise en acier ou DC l'objectif de
l'agglomération 200 bornes d'ici la fin
de l'année 2022 plus de renseignements à
venir sur le site sky.fr on a compris la
référence on a vu la couleur de la
voiture et
je suis grande série bien sûr des années
80 des années 80 années 70 années 80
plutôt je parle sous le contrôle de
Florence Cardin merci et merci Mathilde
pour ses actualités
mais je vous garde encore quelques
minutes Mathilde puisqu' avec vous on va
parler de la maison Calypso c'est un
équipement qui a ouvert en janvier
dernier à plaisir tout à fait Grégory on
en parlait tout à l'heure cette maison
donc a pour but de lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes au total ce
sont une douzaine de professionnels qui
les accueillent chaque semaine et le
site souhaite s'agrandir une nouvelle
maison va bientôt voir le jour on
regarde le reportage de Michael el
Minero et de Mélanie poquet
un nouveau site à quelques mètres
seulement pour continuer à accompagner
les femmes victimes de violence
l'extension de la maison Calypso devrait
voir le jour d'ici 2024 depuis son
ouverture en janvier 2022 le premier
établissement accueilli 187 femmes le
plus grand succès pour
Calypso ce sera quand elle pourra fermer
quand on aura plus besoin de nous voilà
alors bon le monde est bon et on s'est
malheureusement que ce besoin
va perdurer dans le temps on a cinq six
pièces on voit bien que les besoins sont
plus importants que ça puisque le
parcours d'une femme peut durer un an un
an et demi c'est pas on la voit une fois
et puis ça s'arrête là non elle a besoin
de venir de revenir de cheminer a besoin
de participer à des ateliers de
reconstruction de soi et donc ça prend
ça prend du temps
inspiré de la Maison des Femmes de
Seine-Saint-Denis Calypso regroupe une
douzaine de praticiens sage-femme
conseiller conjugal psychologue un
développement qui a attiré l'oeil de la
délégation droit des femmes de
l'Assemblée nationale pour moi c'est
important de venir en délégation et de
venir constater sur place et rencontrer
parce que je crois que on a beaucoup de
travaux et d'audition finalement le fait
de venir rencontrer ça nous permet
d'appréhender
les fonctionnements qui qui marchent
tout simplement au cours d'une année 213
000 femmes sont victimes de violences
physiques et sexuelles elles sont 93 000
victimes de viol ou de tentatives de
viol
et on l'a vu Mathilde c'est un service
important pour les plaisirsoise et aussi
les habitants des environs de plaisir
tout à fait en fait du coup comme je le
disais il y a une douzaine de
professionnels et un centre de
planification familiale pour parler de
tout ce qui est avortement maladies
sexuellement transmissibles
et puis également un gynécologue
obstétricien pas facile à dire qui
s'occupe des mutations
sexuelles ils ont également une
assistante juridique et aussi le
collabore avec le commissariat de
plaisir du coup pour faciliter les
dépôts de plainte des femmes donc c'est
vraiment un suivi global pour écouter et
également soutenir les femmes je
rappelle maison Calypso qui a ouvert en
janvier dernier à plaisir on ouvre une
page culture on reste à plaisir mais on
va parler culture à présent
[Musique]
avec le festival imago qui investit donc
le théâtre Coluche de plaisir vendredi
avec cette pièce c'est la cabane de
l'architecte ou la main tendue de Le
Corbusier on disait tout à l'heure une
création de la compagnie influencenne de
Louise Doutreligne la mise en scène est
ciné est signée de vous Jean-Luc paliez
de représentations une pour les
scolaires à 14h30 et une à 20h30 et pour
cette horaire en soirée un lever de
rideau une représentation sur l'héritage
de Le Corbusier avec les bénéficiaires
et de l'association Art convergence qui
accompagne et personne souffrant de
maladies psychiques et disposant de
talents artistiques vous avez commencé à
pitcher un petit peu la pièce tout à
l'heure on parle de forcément
d'architecture et du lien aussi de Le
Corbusier avec un jeune architecte qui
va aider exactement voilà c'est
l'histoire d'un jeune garçon de 12 ans
qui qui va avoir grâce à Le Corbusier un
destinée nouvelle qui va repartir un peu
sur un bon chemin il va devenir
architecte lui-même là au moment de la
pièce on le prend à 30 ans il est déjà
architecte au cabinet Le Corbusier et il
apprend la mort de Le Corbusier donc il
retourne à Cap Martin et à partir de là
il décide de suivre le cercueil les
étapes du cercueil donc en flashback il
va revoir toute sa vie tout ce qui s'est
passé les étapes importantes les moments
les plus truculents parce que dans la
mémoire généralement sélectionne
toujours le meilleur finalement et bien
cette mémoire on va la voir sur le
plateau et puis au théâtre on fait
revivre les morts donc on va voir le
corps musée lui-même sur le plateau on
va voir aussi tous les personnages de
cette époque c'est-à-dire que on va
couvrir quand même l'étranglorieuses on
a on couvre à peu près 50 ans de la vie
de cet homme et c'était assez
intéressant parce qu'on voit aussi au
travers de sa vie ce qui s'est passé
dans cette époque là mais d'une manière
assez humoristique l'autrice Louise
doutrie a fait un travail scénaristique
assez époustouflant en une heure dix
vraiment on passe 30 ans et on voit pas
on voit pas le temps passer
en coulisse Louise Doutreligne qui est
venu avec vous on va regarder tout de
suite un extrait de la bande-annonce de
cette pièce ok
j'ai un château de 3 mètres 66 par 3
mètres 66 un château où séjourne
l'architecte le plus mal logé de la côte
les échanges entre lui et moi n'était
pas ceux d'un grand maître à un élève
non qui me parlait et qui faisait rêver
le gosse que j'étais il m'a donné des
conseils voilà comme ça tu regardes
alors c'est une pièce on disait qui a
été en résidence au Théâtre Coluche
juste une question avant de vous poser
également la question à vous
pourquoi la figure du Corbusier pourquoi
choisir la figure de Le Corbusier
pourquoi parler d'architecture je vous
posais la question aussi dans un instant
Le Corbusier vous savez pour beaucoup de
gens
c'est c'est le père ou le grand-père des
HLM des bâtiments et tout ça ce qui
n'est pas du tout vrai mais on dit
souvent c'est la faute à Le Corbusier
s'il y a tout ça on l'a même entendu il
y a pas très longtemps par un ministre
donc non c'est pas vrai c'est pas c'est
pas de sa faute malheureusement c'est la
faute de certains héritiers on pourrait
dire mais c'est pas sa faute à lui donc
c'est intéressant d'y aller voir de plus
près et puis là ce qu'on fait dans le
spectacle c'est montrer le Corbusier un
tout petit peu plus humaniste inattendu
aussi parce que justement on essaye un
peu de déjouer ce qu'on a ce qu'on croit
connaître parce que des fois on croit
connaître les choses mais en fait non
donc le théâtre est là aussi pour pour
donner quelques pistes et donner
quelques explications nouvelles je vais
parler un peu tout à l'heure France qu'à
moi pourquoi justement travailler sur
l'architecture pourquoi aussi accueillir
cette compagnie en résidence on va
parler aussi dans un sens se lever de
rideau dans le cadre du festival imago
je trouve formidable de pouvoir
accueillir des compagnies en résidence
parce
que grandes portes ouvertes à tous les
spectateurs ça permet aussi de ne pas en
faire des consommateurs de théâtre mais
des personnes qui qui s'investissent
dans les sujets alors pour moi
l'architecture c'était autant et surtout
en parlant de Le Corbusier c'est autant
un sujet historique qu'un sujet
d'actualité ça ça parle extrêmement
d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire que en fait
il a important pour les gens de savoir
d'où ils viennent pourquoi ils habitent
ces grands ensembles pourquoi il y a des
des vies nouvelles comme Saint-Quentin
l'histoire du béton donc pour moi
c'était une immense porte ouverte pour
pour le public et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
voilà ce qui se passe on a une scolaire
qui regroupe des collégiens de plein
d'établissements avec des enseignants
qui eux sans même savoir que j'ai à
démonter ce projet travailler de leur
côté sur l'architecture ça rejoint les
préoccupations de l'hôpital de plaisir
et de ses résidents qui se sont
passionnés pour ce sujet
en fait c'est ça qui est formidable
c'est c'est d'être une
occasion de rassembler les habitants
d'une ville et des et des villages
environnants et de Saint-Quentin autour
d'une d'un sujet fort voilà
20h30 pour la séance de 20h30 il y a une
création également sur l'héritage de Le
Corbusier par les participants de
l'atelier théâtre mené par Art
convergence avec la compagnie justement
influencelle la mise en scène et signée
d'Alain et Guillot avec le concours de
scarclar Pierre Leroy christine Claude
Denis Élie Luc Mehdi Nancy Noël Sarah
Stéphane Tanguay et Thibault voilà comme
ça ils sont tous
super pourquoi cette collaboration
qu'est-ce qui vous a intéressé pourquoi
travailler sur des handicap justement
parce que le commun de ce sujet c'est
que tout le monde habite on habite tous
quelque part voilà donc il faut essayer
de de comprendre pourquoi et comment on
habite d'ailleurs dans des endroits
absolument différents et cette
différence comme elle fait le commun
aussi voilà et donc nous au théâtre on
aime bien cette histoire là et c'est
vrai que les comédiens ont tout de suite
répondu d'accord Alain Guillot Oscar
Clark qui joue dans le spectacle qui
sont des comédiat formidables
professionnels et ils sont investis à
fond dans ce projet donc ils ont fait
des ateliers avant les vacances de
formation pour initier un peu les
participants à la technique théâtrale et
puis depuis la rentrée il faut vraiment
ils baptisent diminue d'un vrai
spectacle professionnel vraiment que ça
va être présenté sur le grand plateau
devant notre scénographie qu'on a
occulté d'un rideau mais voilà ils vont
avoir la chance de jouer devant un
public sur le grand plateau et pour nous
c'est formidable vraiment et puis alors
ils se sont investis ça a été
extraordinaire et aussi ce qui est
formidable et pour nous c'est c'est
magique c'est le respect qu'ils ont les
uns vis-à-vis des autres ils ont tout
seul des handicaps mentaux et tout ça
mais il se respecte il s'apprécie enfin
ce que m'a dit Alain c'est formidable
qu'est-ce que ça leur apporte Florence
qu'à moins de pouvoir jouer de pouvoir
s'exprimer au travers de l'art du
théâtre
j'ai pas de vivre dans la passion et de
découvrir cet univers du théâtre
j'espère j'espère que ça va les pousser
à aller plus loin et surtout à ce qu'ils
prennent vraiment conscience de leur
valeur et que finalement quel que soit
le handicap qu'on peut avoir on est tous
des handicapés quelque part sûrement
certainement donc se dire bah on s'en
fout nous on peut être acteur on peut
monter sur scène on peut jouer devant un
public et puis demain on fera autre
chose où on fera la même chose on va
aller de l'avant quoi et c'est voilà
c'est une espèce de valorisation et puis
je pense que pour tout le monde pour les
gosses pour les adultes pour tout le
monde ça fait du bien de monter sur une
scène ça fait un bien fou on a compris
l'enrichissement des deux côtés et je
dois dire que l'association a
reconvergence est une association
formidable animée de madmettre par
Laurence
incroyable pour que tout ça puisse avoir
lieu c'est c'est vraiment exceptionnel
d'avoir des associations qui
s'investissent comme ça sur un
territoire pour pour aider valoriser des
gens moi je ne demande qu'à aider
la restitution donc de tout cet atelier
sera à vendredi en levée de rideau je
vous le disais pour environ 15 minutes
sur l'irritage de Le Corbusier et
d'ailleurs c'est gratuit dans la limite
des places disponibles on vous rappelle
ce rendez-vous c'est 20h 20h30 même à
plaisir au théâtre Coluche 14h30 c'est
la représentation pour les scolaires ce
qui vous est indiqué sur autre personne
c'est vraiment multi
notre président de l'hôpital qui sont
pas qui sont pas en capacité de venir le
soir qui viennent donc à la
représentation scolaire avec lui parce
que c'est bien aussi il y a des
personnes âgées qui viennent
l'après-midi c'est aussi le mélange des
personnalités des
âges des cultures de tout si on peut
avoir juste la petite animation pour
avoir le site internet pour trouver
toutes les informations sur notamment la
réservation de ces places merci Florence
qui a moins merci Jean-Luc Paliès d'être
venu parler de cet événement qui a lieu
donc vendredi du côté de plaisir autre
idée de sortie c'est un concert à la
Meurice de trappes et c'est une première
pour cet artiste la chanteuse Olivia
Ruiz
issue de la saison 1 saison 1 même de la
Star Academy sera la fiche de son
spectacle bouche cousu ça parle d'exil
et de résilience elle raconte avec ses
origines espagnoles il raconte même ses
origines espagnoles l'histoire de sa
famille a obligé de fuir la dictature
franquiste on rappelle la carrière
d'Olivia Ruiz 21 album 4 victoires de la
musique trois Globes de Cristal en tant
qu'artiste interprète féminine il reste
des places le tarif va de 12 à 20 euros
info et réservations sur le site trap
mag
aux quatre saisons des balades
commentées sont organisées dans la Haute
Vallée de Chevreuse je vous en parlais
dans les titres la naturaliste Solène
Boivin délivre de nombreux secrets sur
la nature et à l'histoire du parc
naturel régional de la Haute Vallée de
Chevreuse nous avions nous avions
rendez-vous et du côté de rezeux le
vendredi 30 septembre dernier ça remonte
mais il y a des balades qui se déroulent
tout au long de l'année et nous avons
suivi donc cette guide passionnée
regardée est-ce que ça peut être
intéressant pour les oiseaux
les mares
des balades pour les curieux de nature
Solène Boivin organise des promenades
intitulées les grands curieux dans la
Haute Vallée de Chevreuse alors
rencontre du patrimoine de la faune et
de la flore les promeneurs avaient
rendez-vous à Rezé pour suivre la
naturaliste venue éveiller leur
curiosité
la commune a mis en place un différents
petits jardins pour protéger la
biodiversité donc c'est vrai que moi je
vais parler de toutes ces actions qui
comme l'arrêt de l'utilisation des
pesticides qui est très importante pour
pour sauvegarder tous ces milieux qui
sont riches et qui accueillent vraiment
beaucoup d'espèces vivantes une balade
entre nature et patrimoine sur les
traces de Robert Doisneau l'artiste
célèbre pour ses photographies
d'après-guerre a immortaliser des
instants de vie à réseux en s'éloignant
du coeur de la ville l'environnement se
fait plus sauvage l'occasion d'apprendre
les secrets d'un arbuste communément
appelé bonnet d'évêque
on a vraiment des fruits qui vont
s'ouvrir qui vont être rose avec du
orange aussi donc des fruits très très
qui vont perdurer l'hiver qui sont pas
comestibles mais par contre c'est un
arbuste avec lequel on peut faire du
fusain d'Europe très facilement des
balades ludiques pour un public avis de
deux Savoie
c'est toutes les connaissances
naturelles et puis comme je veux en
faire mon métier aussi donc je
m'imprègne et en fait de ce que fait
soi-même découverte d'indices de
présence animale sous le soleil
automnale au hasard d'un sentier le
public a pu apercevoir des lits de
chenilles processionnaires pour se
protéger ses insectes peuvent éjecter
leur poils urticants parfois dangereux
pour l'homme un moment se transformer en
papillon et pour ça elles vont faire des
chrysalides mais dans un cocon qu'on
voit donc elles vont on dit qu'elles
vont se nymphoser donc la
processionnaire du Chanel elle va son
infoser sur le tronc des chaînes c'est
ce qu'on voit sur ce chêne là si vous
êtes un amoureux de la nature et de
l'histoire sachez que ces balades
commentées se déroulent tout au long de
l'année prochain rendez-vous à
Gambaiseuil le vendredi 4 novembre à la
découverte des plantes sauvages
protégées et de l'arbre girafe
je pense qu'à moi Jean-Luc Paillès
Valier vous aviez l'air intéressé
peut-être après la représentation de
vendredi une petite balade en Vallée de
Chevreuse ce weekend absolument c'est
magnifique tous ces fruits nouveaux et
tout ça magnifique département
la nature est magnifique à l'automne on
a l'occasion de se balader à TV 78 le
weekend dernier vous êtes allé cueillir
des champignons en forêt
oui je suis allée j'ai eu l'opportunité
d'aller cueillir des champignons samedi
matin et c'était tout aussi chouette de
faire ce sujet avec des mycologues
experts c'était très intéressant il y
avait des champignons vénéneux oui oui
on en a vu des mortels il faut vraiment
faire attention et
c'est important de le rappeler parce que
en fait finalement il y a plus de
champignons mortels et toxiques que de
champignons comestibles
c'est le nom de l'acteur hypocrites grec
spécialiste de la cueillette des
champignons j'ai fait ça pendant des
années ça me manque terriblement
vous avez l'opportunité de faire des
sorties cueillette de champignons avec
ces micologues
78 avant de se quitter un dernier mot de
météo
[Musique]
et demain mercredi 19 octobre il devrait
y avoir des conditions similaires à
aujourd'hui nuageux sur toutes les
Yvelines le matin avec du brouillard du
côté de Houdan Versailles et
Mantes-la-Jolie où il fera à 15 degrés
14 degrés à Rambouillet quelques rayons
de soleil peut-être attendu ou pas dans
l'après-midi c'est toujours très doux
pour une mi-octobre 20 degrés à
Versailles Rambouillet Mantes-la-Jolie
21 degrés à Houdan et je vous disais
tout à l'heure de la pluie est annoncée
pour la journée de jeudi merci encore à
vous Florence Camoin Jean-Luc Paliès
merci Mathilde d'avoir été avec moi pour
cette émission merci à toutes et à tous
d'avoir suivi ce 7 8 le 7 8 qui touche à
sa fin mais le Replay est disponible
bien sûr sur notre site Internet et
notre application mobile très belle
soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]